hello everyone
my name is janik dalto i'm the
scientific affair manager for
nano and i'll be uh your host today
and i would like to welcome you to this
exciting webinar featuring
uh lila alcatabi from the kosher
hospital in paris
and alexander ocean from the red belt
medical center in nime again
the netherlands dr alcatabi and ocean
will present us with their new results
from their comparative studies
between classical cytogenetics and by
nano for the identification
of structural variants in constitutional
or cancer sample
i would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive
please ask questions during the
presentation and to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box on this side of the screen
you can also share on social media by
clicking the tab
on the left side of the screen before
getting started i would just like to
take a few minutes
to present you with the binance
technology
ngs still struggles to resolve complex
variants
or a variance of um ovarian spirit in a
repetitive sequences sorry
to answer that by nano is based on
sequencing but just like
uh you would do with a microscope by
looking at metaphase spreads
by nano brings you the true structure of
a genome
we do this by visualizing ultra high
molecular weight dna molecules using a
scanner we developed the sapphire
similar to what you would do with a
whisky typing let me show you how it
works
the sapphire workflow uses the chips to
analyze dna
we have kits for dna extraction and
labeling and our
own free analysis tool
let's break down the workflow together
our technology relies on the direct
imaging of ultra-long
dna molecules that's why we developed a
fast protocol
where we lyse the cells in solution then
we use a nanobind disk that will tightly
bind the dna
molecules and protect them from any
mechanical stress
and now you simply wash
simply wash it elude it and it is that
simple
the protocol is uh fast and perfectly
automatical
you know that ffp sample are just not
good enough to be used with by nano as
the fixative will
startly decorate created in new
molecules we can do this with a fresher
frozen material
blood cultural cells fresher frozen
tissue
or tumor biopsies for as low
as 10 milligrams one main difference
with the long-range sequencing is that
our molecules have an average length of
about 400 kb
and go all the way up to megabases
once we have the megabase size dna the
next step is to
label it here an enzyme will recognize a
six-space sperm motif
and attach a fluorophore directly to the
dna the dna will also be counterstained
with an
intercalating dye there's no naking and
no probe involved here
it's a single enzymatic reaction
labeling a six-base pair sequence that
appears every 6 kb
on average and the pattern is unique
throughout the genome
so at any time we know where the dna
molecule belongs in the genome
then we linearize the dna we use
electrophoresis to pull the dna
into nano channels the array looked like
this what you have on the top
hundreds of thousands of channels in
parallel the stretched dna
is the bottom channel so the the blue
signal is the counterstain backbone
and the green you see are the labels we
attach to the dna
all throughout the genome the principle
is similar to karyotyping but at a much
greater resolution
and once again the pattern is unique
throughout the genome so we know where
the molecule belongs
in the in the genome now the instrument
will cycle the molecules into the
channels and image them
over and over again cycle them until you
get the massive
yields you need to analyze complex human
genomes
you can go anywhere between 100x to
1600x coverage for exactly the same
price
the only variable being the time you run
the instrument
once we collect these images the
software will perform a general assembly
of the molecule meaning we align
every molecule we image just based on
the label pattern
the denobo aspect is important as when
you work from a highly
rare range material you do not want to
force the
assembly to reference that would not
make sense here
and then we compare to the reference in
this case the reference is in green
we will align our maps geneva assembled
to the reference
and look for differences in this case
you see a deletion because the space
between our labels decreases
and of course all the knowledge from the
reference still comes along meaning that
we know where the genes are because the
pattern is unique throughout the genome
so that way we can detect each meta type
of structural variation
automatically genome-wide starting at
500 base pair
we can detect insertion deletion repeat
expansion
uh we detect tandem duplication
inversion automatically at 30 kb and
above
translocation and inversion are really
hard to detect with sequencing and we
are very good at it
we also developed a specific pipeline
for complex heterogeneous genomes that
leverages the tremendous coverage
and looks at svs at the single medical
level
and this is crucial when you have a
colono-population lacking
like a leukemia this tool is a
complementary to the universamb pipeline
i've just presented
and allows you to detect all structure
variants
5 kb and above automatically genome-wide
down to one percent a little fraction
and that's a game changer
and no one else can do it
you can visualize our genome in in our
browser
uh called the binomial axis and you can
see a circus plot like this
where each of the chromosomes are shown
in concentric circle
different types of svs are present
here as dots the purple line and mill
are translocation between each of the
chromosomes
if you just click on any of these events
you can zoom
on the map that just popped up on your
screen where you can see the de novo map
aligning to each chromosome here it's a
translocation
we can even show the molecules that we
image with our system
but on top of that all the sv call will
be
filtered to a control database so you
can just filter only somatic events rare
events that are not present in the
control population
and of course the annotated sv call can
be exported at the standard pcs file
optical mapping has rated a lot of
interest in the human genetic fields
whether it is to
modernize old cytogenetic methods such
as
karyotyping to quickly identify
actionable svs in cancers such as the
amtrak fusion partners
but it also led to numerous discoveries
of fusions
never described before i invite you to
visit
our website or to download the vignettes
you will have
on the side of your screen but i cannot
wish
of better results to illustrate what
binance can bring you
than those the story of
our two speakers are about to present to
you
so without further due is it my pleasure
to welcome dr
lala el catabe from the kosher hospital
in paris and dr alexander ocean from the
radbag medical center
in the netherlands dr alcathab is an
associate professor in cytogenetics at
the description university and kosher
hospital in paris
she's in charge of the laboratory of
non-invasive
prenatal screening and fatal employees
for parisian public hospitals
she's also involved in the diagnostics
of chromosomal abnormalities related to
developmental and reproductive disorders
in addition she leads research at koch
institute on gene transcription and how
this function
is impacted in case of chromosomal
abnormalities
dr ocean is an associate professor and
group leader
at red belt medical center his research
group is called immunogenomics
with a 50 percent affiliation each at
the department
of uh internal medicine and human
genetics
in the last years he has shown that
application of noble
and disruptive technology will allow new
scientific insight in rapid
translational uh into clinical and
diagnostic practice
uh for now please dr alcatabi the floor
is yours
thank you hi everyone thank you for
being here
and thank you for presenting me uh for
giving me this
opportunity to present our work so uh
for today i'm gonna present the results
of our collaborative study
uh between my lab in paris my french
collaborators in
leon clermont and the railroad genetic
center in naimegan
with alexander so she so
uh let me just uh give you
uh uh yeah please first of all uh just
to precise that
part of the red boot reagent cost of
this study was covered by bionic numbers
um so let me just set a few things first
uh as you know structural variants
account for a large part of uh
variation in the human genome and this
leads to phenotype variability
but sometimes it leads also to diseases
and especially developmental and
reproductive disorders
so in the past years uh we've all
known the expansion of clinical genomics
thanks to the development of new
technologies
among which sequencing high throughput
sequencing and this
led to new discoveries and an increased
diagnosis rate for these diseases
but the detection of structural
variation is still challenging
that's why karyotype and chromosomal
microarray analysis are still used
uh at least for reproductive disorders
for the first one and developmental and
malformative
con disorders for the second one
as uh all of us know karyotype has a
very low resolution
estimated at five to ten megabases and
microarray
do not detect balanced rearrangement nor
provides information on the location of
an operation in the genome
or its orientation so
we thought to test this
new technology because we thought it
may improve the diagnosis of structural
variation
in particular particular balanced ones
for our patients so
we joined our forces with the lime again
and we started this study
uh on unknown chromosomal aberrations
so this was led
on patients who were referred to us for
reproductive disorders
or intellectual deficiency developmental
disorders or
multiple congenital anomalies for which
the
current standard of care first line test
is stereotype
or dna microarg so whenever uh
these techniques detected a large sv
or cnv and we had leftover material for
a patient then
we just included that patient and to
realize the genome mapping using bionin
so here is a description of our samples
85 symbols were included
as you can see on the left side of the
screen
um the indications were quite uh
diverse corresponding to what we have in
a clinical lab
and on the right uh side
of the screen you can see the different
cytogenetic investigations that were
carried so in
about one-third of cases we had
karyotype
another third cma analysis and the last
third
both of these
in total we had 114 aberrations
uh 50 of them were balanced and the
other
50 unbalanced and uh the
distribution of the kind of aberrations
were
very diverse again here as you can see
we had even
isochromosomes ring chromosomes complex
operations
but most of them were deletions and
duplication
as well as translocations as expected
here are the first uh overview of the
results so this
is the average number of calls that we
got in the the dark
blue shows the total wealth
number of of svs the
marine blue in the middle uh
shows the svs after filtering
in particular with the population
frequency and the light blue
bar shows the numbers after overlapping
with genes
so uh sorry because it looks like small
but in total we had just a handful
number
of svs after filtering 70
in total which were distributed between
different
kind of aberrations
so just to set the the
principal results first we got hundred
percent course
concordance except for aberrations
within
uh unmapped unmappable regions of the
human genomes
of course centromeres as well as a p arm
of apocentric chromosomes and here are
three examples of those
where you can see in the red
[Music]
font the breakpoints that couldn't be
located now i'm gonna show you a few
examples so that you can
see how it looks like the first one uh
was
a karyotype from a men showing a clean
filter
syndrome and as you can see it was a
47xy
karyotype so genome imaging uh
showed the aberration using the cnb
core system so here is the circus plot
in red the region
corresponding to sex chromosomes and
here is the zooming of that region so
you can
see from the cnv trap
which is shown here by the blue plot
that you have uh coverage on chromosome
x that is
uh twofold higher than the coverage on
chromosome x
and as high as the coverage on common on
on
autosomal chromosomes next to it which
which indicates that it's
xxy stereotype the second example
is an example of a four megabase
duplication that was detected by
cma here and here is the result from bio
nano and you can see
shown in red again uh duplication
on commas on 19 and when you zoom in
here again on the cnv call you have the
green plot that shows
that there is a gain in this region and
this is shown
as well by this sv code
okay so same here and this is a smaller
cnb
500 kb on chromosome 8 and
the cma result here from snip re
shows the deletion and here again
with bionano results you can see
by the red arrow loss or deletion
chromosome 8 and again a zoom in
and the blue plot which corresponds to
the coverage
shows that there was a loss at this
region
so here is the representation by uh
structural variation
and you can see in the uh the
lower side of the the image the green
map
corresponds to the reference the blue
one corresponds to the sample
and the labeling shows that there is a
loss of this region
here again a translocation but i'm gonna
skip the translocation maybe since we
have a lot of examples of translocations
and we might be short in time today
but i'm open to questions to discuss
about it later on
so let's go to another example that
shows an inversion on chromosome 3
here is a the karyotype of this women
on the right side side you can see a
zooming of chromosome 3
the right one is shows a
bar centric inversion on the q arm
of chromosome 3. here is
a simple circle spot view again from
bionano
that shows that there is an event on
chromosome 3 and
when you zoom in you can see your
molecules
on the patient map track you have two
molecules well at least
two maps that
show there is an inversion between these
two regions
from chromosome 3 below of it
you have this detailed
and this is a 23 megabase inversion
this example was from a little girl who
showed growth resization and development
and delay
for which a stereotype showed a marker
and uh bionano can show you with the
circles plot here so this is the circle
spot only for chromosome
x and you can see there is an event
uh between the centromere and the q
region of chromosome
x and if you zoom in uh into the genome
map of this
this this patient you can see here again
uh that there is a little
map that shows a junction between
the left or left sides of the chromosome
and the right size of the chromosome and
this
corresponds to the the marker that is
the ring
chromosome so
now i'm gonna take a little time to show
you
in detail some other examples that
represent for me
additional potential input of this
technology to diagnosis in genetic
diseases
so the first one is an example where
this technology
can allow for genotype phenotype
correlations
so let's see this one is a little boy
who was presenting intellectual
deficiency and other
uh phenotype and the karyotype
showed apparently balance trunk location
between chromosome 9
and 17. so the image represents
a result from bionano and it shows
on the upper line the chromosome
9 on the lower one chromosome 17
these are the references and between
them
a little uh blue
box that corresponds to the patient map
so let's zoom in it makes
it makes it easy so again
the blue track corresponds to the
patient
track the green ones to the reference
the upper green
is chromosome 17 here the lower one
is chromosome 9 and you can see that the
blue line
maps both to chromosome 9
in the bottom and chromosome 17
on the upper side and we
also indicate the genes
that are involved in this region from
chromosome 17
and you can see that the gene cancel one
would be disrupted and the
haploid insufficiency of this gene is
already known to
cause coolant derive syndrome
which leads to intellectual deficiency
deficiency and
fascial dysmorphism which was consistent
with the
patient's phenotype
another interest of using this
technology is
to allow for the direction of cryptic
balanced aberration
so here is an example of a circus
platform
bionano again that shows a translocation
between
chromosome 7 and chromosome 10.
here is again the zoom in same than
previous one the blue line corresponds
to the patient map
the green one to the reference the upper
green is
reference chromosome 7 the lower one is
chromosome 10
and here again we can see the
translocation between the q
arm of chromosome 10 and the
p arm of chromosome 7.
here is the corresponding karyotype that
just to show you that this
is very hard to see as a translocation
so on the right side you have the
zooming of the karyotype
comes from between the chromosome 7 and
chromosome
10 and the red arrows
indicate the derivative chromosomes
which are
very hard to see for the translocation
again bionano can also provide
information on the orientation of the
duplicated segments
and here is an example of this um
this is a result from cma that shows the
duplication
on the p arm of chromosome 8.
here is the result from fish analysis
so i circled the commas
both chromosome 8 the
white circle indicates the normal
chromosome
and the red circle indicates the
rearranged chromosome
and you can see that the
the green and red label which
corresponds to
two back
probes are face to face
uh if i can say in the red circle
chromosome
which is indicative of inverted
duplication
so when you look at this case using
genome mapping genome imaging with bio
nano
you can easily see both events
so on the cnv call track you can see
a terminal deletion which i didn't talk
about and
a duplication
and this duplication you can
deduct from the sv call track that it is
inverted and
interestingly although breakpoints
of the duplication were located within
segmental duplications
this event was detected
we can also reveal an unravel complexity
behind apparent simplicity what i meant
by this is such cases
with here apparently simple
although three-way translocation between
three chromosomes chromosome three
chromosome 13 and chromosome
5 as shown on the karyotype below
but when you have uh the results from
genome imaging with bionano you can see
from the circus plot between chromosome
3 on the right and chromosome 5
on the left that there are much more
events than the ones that were expected
and
he is zooming on commas on three that
shows
a lot of events uh inversion
deletions that were indicative of
chromosomes
and i will end my examples with this one
so this is a case of a translocation
between commas on x and chromosome 1.
the breakpoint was
we were not able to map this breakpoint
even using
ngs and genome mapping with
bionano helped us for this case
since here again you can see
the middle track the blue line
from the patient that maps both to
chromosome 1
and chromosome x and this
interrupts again disrupt
gene called energy and a4
for which insufficient
hyperinsufficiency is responsible of
idafd and our
patient had moderate intellectual
deficiencies so this
allowed also a diagnosis for this case
so to conclude uh our study revealed a
high success rate
using this technology with hundred
percent concordance with chromosomal
micro
analysis 100 percent concordance with
karyotype when breakpoints lie within
mappable regions
of the human genome and
uh this uh
very large molecule analysis allows to
pick up
small and large svs and even in cases
where
breakpoints lie within segmental
duplication
so we expect significant benefits uh
to diagnosis first genotype phenotype
correlations for
uh cases a lot of cases with
unbalanced balanced violence or as well
as unbalanced
new discoveries in unfold cases
the workflow is quite simple with this
unique technique that could replace
three of the techniques for now the
easy technical and analytical process is
uh very appreciated with no
bioinformatics analysis
no overwhelming cause after filtering as
we saw
and this is inadequation with the
routine analysis process
the other advantage advantage of not
having
a genome sequence
is that we will have less incidental
findings which is important in case of
investigations for reproductive
disorders for example
and uh to me at least although uh
robertsonian translocations and
centromeric breakpoints are not
detectable for now
we expect a high balance of benefit to
risk
which would favor the
adoption of this technology to our
current investigation tools portfolio
we are even but maybe we will discuss
about these
uh for people who are interested in this
technology
uh we think that uh few cell counting
could um be just a complementary
exam test to add to it
so please follow us the publication is
to come
by uh two puzzle box
monterey tour and uh cornelia neville
who have been working hard on this
project and please just
allow me to thank all our collaborators
at radwood
university medical center as well as my
french collaborators
in particular caroline schubbart in neo
city malaysia
in claremore pharaoh and my colleagues
at kosher hospital show michelle dupont
and edison ober
as well as all other clinicians and
genetic laboratory um that were involved
in these studies
i just love your medicine for funding
part of these experiments
and the bio nano team because they
helped us a lot
with the analysis thank you
all right i had to admit myself
so thank you very much leila i think we
agreed that i definitely follow up
on that my name is alex hoysham and as
janik kindly introduced i work in
naimegan
the netherlands so i'll directly follow
up upon
layla's really nice talk and then we
decided to have the q a
right after my presentation
so i'll just try to show you a little
bit of the follow-up work we've done
next to the constitutional study that
layla just presented
and that will be on some novel
discoveries of structure variants in
reality these cases
and that is in contrast to the cases
that layla presented where we knew
uh that the aberrations were present
however we refined several of those
athleticism
and in addition i will also show you how
we can use bionano
uh for comprehensive somatic as we
detection
in particular in leukemia
and with that just again to make sure
bionicle supported us with some reagents
throughout this study
my first slide of the presentation is if
i just have to explain how buy now works
to cite each network they immediately
get thrilled uh well some people that
mainly worked on sequencing may still
have some
issues with understanding all the
benefits and and where we are with
bioname at the moment
so the easiest example i can usually
give is it actually is very similar to
karyotyping and i think that's why
i termed it sometime back next
generation psychogenetics
um so it still is looking at large
chunks of chromosomes
so just imagine you would be a
cytogeneticist so this would be
chromosome one that we you would look at
imagine you could just zoom in to each
and every cyto band
and just have a massive zoom in for that
and many many bands up two thousand
bands
for chromosomal bands you wouldn't be
used to that but that is in fact what by
another can now offer
and as such it still maintains all the
other benefits
that can give you but it just insights
to genetics on steroids with
something like half a million bands
compared to 500 bands that you usually
would get
so that basically would be cited
genetics with a 10 000 volt improved
sensitivity
while still maintaining the benefits it
still is a genome-wide analysis
it still gives you the positional
information and
in principle it also allows you to look
at single molecules
and we'll come to some of these
advantages in the next slide
um say this is just an overview slide of
what we've done
also we are still quite new to the field
of optical mapping
by using bayerno so we basically have
the instrument in adding for a little
bit more than a year but due to the
covet 19 crisis obviously we haven't
been as productive in the last
three months as we planned but this is
basically what i
can show you today is the output of the
first year used by another in-house
um so as layla has nicely shown we
roughly added half of those samples that
later presented today
uh since then we've done few more
samples for constitutional sites and
genetic aberrations so those by
and large or samples that had a known
aberration by carry typing fish or
microarray
and we just asked the simple question
can we find those true positive events
back
and as layla has shown it seems to be
relatively easy we directly hit
100 percent concordance
in addition still talking about
constitutional so germline
aberrations we couldn't uh resist to
also
try this mobile technology on some of
our unsolved rare disease cases and i'll
show
some of these examples so we totally ran
50 or so of those samples
belonging to 20 projects and so far i
would consider 5 of those 20 solved
or we at least have very interesting
leaps and i'll present two of those
today
and ultimately when we saw this
technology we thought this may be really
good for leukemia but because they are
cytogenics actually a mix of all
different hygienic
tools is still the gold standard um so
we also compared 50 bikini samples to
the routine workup that they usually get
and i'll show you both of these examples
today
um just one high level summary
what we usually do so for the
constitutional samples we usually find
with just generating
80 to 100x genome coverage data
that usually is used to build a de novo
assembly of the genome
and then we have a combined sv and cnv
calling from that inovo assembly by
comparing it to the reference genome
that is all the work that layla just
very nicely presented
the samples we have used in the first
year is a
wide mix of sample inputs just as a
reminder we can't use readily isolated
dna but we use this very special
protocol that by nana has optimized
and we use various blood types bone
marrow aspirates
but also various cell lines so far and
that works
very nicely different from the
constitutional analysis
the leukemia data that i'll show you
later obviously
there we need higher genome coverage to
gain even more sensitivity because the
main target there would be to look for
somatic
and acquired aberrations so we usually
go for a cleonadex genome coverage there
and then instead of running a de novo
assembly we use the latest tools
released by by nano and that is a
so-called rare variant pipeline
that is specialized for somatic events
but again here
similar to what you do for contribution
operations it makes use of two different
algorithms
that allows an sv and a c and v calling
and i'll give you examples a little
later but for now let me start to show
you some of our research cases
um so when having the instrument we
directly thought okay this may be nice
to
tackle some of the unsolved reality
these cases that we have
collected over the years some people may
anticipate that this may unravel some
structural variants that remain
refractory to ngs detection
or some other people even refer to those
events
that those may lay in the camouflaged
parts of the human genome
and if i just give you the three main
categories of
rare disease patients or initial
approaches to that
those usually were families or cases
that already had
known linkage region in the genome
equally we studied some cases
with a classical recessive disease where
only one pathogenic mutation was
discovered
and we tried to use bionano to find the
second missing allele and then we had
some very
severe sporadic cases where we speculate
that the
disease causing mutation may just be a
hidden denoble structural variant
that we couldn't detect otherwise
um all those samples were the vast
majority is obviously collected in-house
um in naimegan but we're also involved
in two large-scale studies the sulfur d
and the cross omics initiative and
obviously we're open to other
collaborative studies and i'll show you
some of that
as well now on the next slide because
our first example
is a collaboration uh with my former
colleague colin kuiper who now works at
the prince's maxima center in utrecht
also in the netherlands
roland and his team and collaborators
are interested
in a rare but very severe condition
called atypical territory to rupture
tumors these are very rare but
aggressive tumors that are usually
diagnosed in childhood
those are usually present as severe
brain tumors
mainly affecting the cerebellum and
there is already a known cause
and those are mutations in smart b1
and it is known that one third of cases
present with a german mutation in smart
b1
while two-thirds of sporadic cases
present with a double hit somatically
in the case i present today there was a
suspicion for
a genetic predispositions or germline
mutation
uh so holland and his clinical
colleagues were already studying
uh this family for two years or more
because in this family one unfortunately
a very young girl already died
of her brain tumor and the atrt
condition
however the parents still had another
wish for another child
so they were curious to understand
whether there would be a
recurrence risk due to a german mutation
or not
in the tumor of this girl there was
evidence
that smartb1 was affected based on
immunochemistry
however it was still unknown whether it
was a sporadic somatic event
or really a germline event
say for that purpose they used germline
dna
and offered diagnostic assays by sanger
sequencing mlpa and even exome
sequencing
but no germline mutation was found and
holland's team also did genome
sequencing by standard short read
illumina sequencing
and still was unable to find uh
sorry i was distracted by the chat but
we're still unable to find a mutation
in this gene
so then they sent germline material and
ebv cell line to us and i'm again
we performed bio nano optical mapping
generator free analytics genome coverage
and did very simple standard filtering
and you see all those filter settings on
the right hand side
what it basically comes down to if you
just do very simple filtering
and only focus on the structural
variants that have never been seen in
any control
we end up with 35 rare structural
variants in this case
and then obviously we zoom in to the
most important locus for this disease
one of those 35 rare events hits the
smart b1 gene
as you can see here the upper bar shows
the gene tracks the green bar again
similar to the previous presentation
is the reference genome with the
suspected label sites for the bio nano
labels
and the blue bar represents the lenovo
assembly and there you can see that a
small person
is inserted if i zoom in
a little bit further then you can
directly see the individual molecules
that support this event
so this sufficient molecule is really
showing reliably that this must be an
insertion
and if you look at the size what you
would expect based on the wildcat marker
distance
uh you would expect that these two
markers have a five kb distance
uh but in the patient heaters i guess we
saw an insertion of
2.8 kb and we even saw an additional
label
other than that obviously we don't have
any sequence context for
this aberration so in our view this very
likely
is the germline mutation that
that was looked for for so much time by
so many different
technologies it is most likely inserted
between
introns one and three of the smart p1
gene um
however that's probably the only
downside so far we don't have
or had at that stage the exact inserted
material
but then initially we thought oh but it
should be easy we just do a long range
pcr over that locus
but for still unknown or not fully
understood reasons
none of the pcr approaches actually
worked so we speculated that
maybe repetitive dna that may be entered
here
and actually we just finished those
validations
and what we just did because none of the
targeted approaches work we simply did
pack biosequencing
so we used our latest pet bio sql 2 and
produced
a hi-fi genome so very high quality ccs
coverage genome
eight-fold coverage uh with a median
read length of 20 kb
and this supported an insertion exactly
where we expected it and in this case an
intro one of smart b1
this is shown by the purple bar and
that's two of those insertions
i'll just show you the next
field here if you click on the inserted
sequence we may get a feeling why it was
difficult to validate it
there is a very repeat which region on
the left
boundary and the right boundary of this
inserted material
and if i tell you now that this sequence
especially at the boundaries but the
entire sequence
really limits a virtual transposon in
particular an sva each retrotransposon
that is inserted so by having now base
pair evidence we're really sure now that
this is
the germline aberration that we were
hunting for
what remains to be seen or what is still
an open question i should say
is how can an intronic insertion lead to
a loss of function of the allele i mean
we have evidence on the protein
level of the tumor that that is really
the case
however how this may disrupt splicing is
still currently
looked for in holland typer's research
lab
but obviously intriguingly it is now to
speculate how many more of those jumping
ritual transposons do we have in the
human genome
and how many other rare disease cases
may this explain that is very intriguing
okay fast moving to the second case i
wanted to show you today
we obviously study a lot of sporadic
cases with severe intellectual
disability that's what we also did here
so this is a sporadic case born to
healthy parents
and in this particular case we've done
everything we had so far our in our
genomics portfolio
classical follow-up for such a cases c
microarrays exome sequencing when
usually followed on a research site by
genome sequencing
and in this particular case even by take
biology sequencing sequencing
most of that is published data for this
particular case and the longer data
are just submitted and unfortunately
none of these previous technologies
found
anything disease causing in this case so
we speculate that maybe this one case
may have a hidden structure varying that
escape the detection by all the other
methods
so what we again did is we just did
optical mapping for this case
the lenovo assembly if you look at all
the structure variants at close to
six or seven thousand or so if you then
again just do very simple filtering
by filtering for events that are rare so
never seen any controlled genomes in
this case 200
then we end up with 30 to 50 or so
structural variant general white
but in this particular case we because
we suspected a denoble event
we also included the parents and just
clicked one extra filter saying
show me only the variants that are not
present in mom and dad
and that's what you then see here is one
predicted denoble deletion
but then just click on this one event we
end up in a very complex region of the
human genome
which is indicated by the orange bars at
the bottom this is one of the most
complicated sequential duplication
regions
on 17q21 so what we saw in this patient
is actually
that there was a paternally inherited
duplication overlapping
with the nsf pseudogene number one
but in addition just particularly
partially overlapping with this
duplicated sequence
uh predicted the novo deletion actually
a quite large one 121 kb
so you could directly wonder why wasn't
that picked up by any of the previous
sequencing based efforts
and the answer may lay in the complexity
of this region
it really fully overlaps with a highly
complex segmental duplication
on the next slide we see our validation
experiments that we just recently did so
designing primers
on the mutational wheel only amplifies
the mutated lead in the patient
but we don't see any hints in the father
or the mother
this amplicom was then sequenced again
by take bio sequencing but in this case
not genome sequencing
but rather um amplicon-based sequencing
that spanned this region obviously and
on the next slide
oh sorry that slide out um
this amplicon sequencing uh did two
things it first of all validated the
events
but also gave us exact break points base
per resolution
and it showed that in fact this came
down to quite exactly 121 kb
d noble deletion identified by bioman
now validated by picked by amplicon
sequencing
the gene that is disrupted in this
region is obviously
very interesting what that could be
say obviously this dean of event
happened in one of the most complex
regions
this is the terminal segmental
duplication of the 17q2131 micro
deletion syndrome also known as colon
the freeze
as shown briefly by layla for a
different purpose
um but within the spin of the lesion the
gene that may be disrupted or is likely
disrupted by this deletion
is a gene called nsf which is
interesting is that this gene has an
important brain function and is mainly
expressed in brain
however as already shown in the previous
plot this gene has absolute gene
nsfp1 and actually both genes together
are very copy number variable
anything between two and eight copies to
my understanding have been reported in
the general population
but to my understanding uh there was
never a case described with just one nsf
copy and that could be what we are
facing here in our patient
so it is far from any evidence but it is
very tempting to speculate
that potentially haploid sufficiency of
these locus may cause disease
and what actually fostered this further
is that there's a very recent report
from a wonderful
research performed in japan and this
group identified denver point mutations
in nsf one
in patients with specific forms of
epilepsy
however they speculate in their paper
that most likely their effect is a
dominant negative effect
nevertheless this is the first evidence
that nsf is a
disease gene so we're now trying to
gain extra evidence in our patient to
see whether the only denoble event that
was now found
finally by nano may be even involved in
disease
right now i'd like to switch gears for
the last few minutes
and just give you some highlights of our
leukemia study
for those that are interested in details
because due to the
shakes time i can't give you all the
details please visit our pre-print
that we put on by archives to just keep
it very short
the beauty of that study is we used 48
leukemia samples
to study all their previously known
somatic and
acquired events that have been
identified previously by carry tapping
fish and or cmv microarrays
and also similar to the study layla
presented we had 100
concordance for all the structural
variants that were
at least present in 10 or more variant
allele fraction
uh this is just the overall average
qc for all the 48 samples the only two
aspects that are important here is that
we
generated 280 x coverage of all those 48
genomes on average
and the average molecule size is 262
kilobases
but individual molecules are much much
longer
this is the overall averages of
structure variants that we find per case
just to give you a flavor
these are the results of the so-called
rare variant tool
or reverend pipeline so that is
different from uh that i've
used in the study and that on average
shows us
close to 1500 structure variants per
sample however of those
only 44 on average are rare events
in addition we can benefit from uh
a potential overlap with genes and then
we're only facing
uh on average 25 or 26 such a variance
per case
in addition we can use the cnv tool that
you basically get on top for free
and that shows us on average 9 games and
50 losses
however these numbers may be inflated by
some of the highly complex cases that
i'll show you in a second
just to give you a flavor of what we
usually see in these leukemia samples so
here we had a
case with the known balance
translocation
uh on the left-hand side you see the
genome white circus plot you've now seen
plenty of those and on the right-hand
side you see a zoom in
to chromosomes 11 and 14 that was the
known balance simplification in this
case
if i just click on the purple line on
the right
that directly guides us again to the map
again the sample map of this leukemia
sample is in the middle in blue
and it maps to chromosome 11 reference
and the chromosome 14 reference
on the bottom and the predicted break
point indicated
by uh the purple bits is directly
showing us that this is a balanced event
uh fusing most likely the ight and the
ctn
d1 locals as just circled here
i should say that usually the breakpoint
resolution comes down to just a very
kb for most of the cases
because those are somatic events we can
actually just click on the sample map
and we actually then directly see how
many molecules support this event and
we'd already have a flavor for
how much how high the fraction of
affected billion is
this is just a summary of three
additional translocations that we found
so there were three cml cases involved
in this
proof of concept study they all carry
the hallmark operation of cml
mainly a philadelphia chromosome between
chromosome 9 and 22
which obviously leads to the bcr able
fusion on the left hand side you see the
able breakpoints
in all the three samples so you see two
different breakpoints enable one
and on the right hand side you see the
bcr breakpoint again two different
breakpoints are predicted based on the
bional results
in summary i can say that usually the
the breakpoint resolution we get from
bionano
is much better than what we would get
from traditional fish
ultimately we can also start seeing very
complex cases in much greater detail
than ever before
in these cases we had one sample with
chromotrips of chromosome
8 also shown on the zoom in on the right
hand side
and a monozone e7 for the sake of
complexity let's just focus on
chromosome 8 for now
on the next slide we see the actual map
of this chromotriptic chromosome eight
and what you just have to imagine here
each and every blue fragment
is a map of fused pieces of chromosome
eight
so in principle we would now for the
first time be able to
completely rebuild the structure of this
chromotripsis
just based on the by nano optical maps
final base for visualization you see one
sample for which we had cmd microarray
results with a trisomy 12
and a smaller deletion chromosome 13. uh
the upper
approach is our standard asymmetric
cytoskin hd array
and the lower bar is the new gene white
cmd visualization
that is very much array-like that by
another now presents
and then again on the right-hand side
you see the zoom-in and actually
it's almost indistinguishable from the
error results that we're so much
used to um
ultimately sorry for a little mess up on
the slide i did not see
that was not intended just in addition
because in principle we only looked at
variation that we knew previously just
for fun we filtered
all the rare structure variants
identified in all 48 examples
of all of those 95 presented with rare
inter-chromosomal transportation 23 of
those were a unique call that led to
potential
gene fusions and if i just show you one
of those examples there were several
known ones in there obviously like bcr
able that i've shown you before
but in this one case there was a fusion
that at least to my knowledge was never
described before
for sure not in this case but also not
in other leukemia samples
and that is the likely fusion between
the gene agbl4
and rungs one on the next slide again
let's
zoom in to the map of the fusion again
this is really
most likely breaking these two genes or
fusing them together
obviously to people familiar to the
leukemia field ranks one is a very no
well-known player but at least to me
agbl4 was not ever described in leukemia
but it is interesting that hbl4 fusions
have been described in other cancers
at least for lung adenocarcinomas that
was a known fusion partner for other
oncogenes so this is just to highlight
one
of these examples but actually all the
data is online so if you want to
play with our data all of that is on our
preprint
as i've shown you before just to wrap
this part up
i've shown you briefly some highlights
of our study of 48 leukemia samples that
have been previously tested by carry
typing fish
and cnv microarrays they consisted of 37
simple cases and 11 complex cases
and in summary we find 100 concordance
for all
simple cases and we also have full
concurrence for 10 out of 11 complex
cases
in one complex case we missed three
operations that likely had a variant
delay section that was just below 10
percent
getting that actually counted is not
even so trivial
um so as such uh we also
have additional evidence now that for
some of our very complex cases
uh the events that we anticipated were
even more complex
and are there now to say that genome
imaging so bionano is usually much
closer to
the to the true underlying aberration
nature
of the event just as a final highlight
one more slide of something very new
and we just played with some of the data
as some of you may know
in leukemia regions of homozygosity are
very interesting or in particular
losses of feature zygosity that happen
somatically
in this example i show you uh just a
plot of all the sc codes along
chromosome 1.
and you see that we see different cults
some homozygous some heterozygous calls
if i just go
to all the events in this case including
the germline aberrations and the somatic
events
but if you go to chromosome seven this
plot really looks different
and the dotted line in the middle just
gives you an
averaging window if you look at
chromosome 7 then we see a total loss of
future zygosity for chromosome 7q
and that was a known event in this case
say this was a large
region of a loss of heater zygosity and
although it's not supported yet by
banana as an automatic calling
it now seems to be relatively easy to
spot that in the data and we're quite
excited about this extra feature now
so again look at the data play with the
data if you wish a lot of the data is
given in the supplements for
downloads and tables and as such that
brings me to my summary slides
and a little bit of an outlook i hope
i've shown you
actually the first part layla has shown
you um
we can get full concordance for all the
operations
in the constitutional aberration field
except for those breaking in the
centromeres obviously for leukemia we
also generate
full concordance hundred percent one's
operations are in a million direction
higher than 10 percent
um and for that reason um i mean i'm
just a researcher
but i'm carefully optimistic that
bionano may be the first technology that
could
completely replace cytogenetics and as
such that would be carry tapping arrays
and fish
as a researcher i'm probably even more
thought about the discoveries we've
recently made
so the structure variants that were
undetectable by other means
are now popping up by the bio nano
analysis and that obviously
gives us very interesting leads for our
own research
i honestly believe that optical mapping
may allow a true revolution of
cytogenetics
and that's what i also like to call this
next generation cytogenics
and this is just starting and then as a
final teaser i think there's
some really cool new innovations coming
additional colors uh
additional labels uh duval evans team
steamed lab is working on really fancy
methylation
and extra structure variants by banana
and
what was mentioned briefly bionic is
that you can generate for the same price
much higher
coverage now which even allows you to
find some method mutations that are in
one percent
where in the life fraction or lower
with that i'd like to thank all my
collaborators
obviously a massive thank you again to
leyla for the wonderful collaboration
with her and all her collaborators
particularly for the work shown in my
slides today i'd like to thank
trombo and cornelia for their wonderful
work over the last year
and many other colleagues from nymegan
the entire team
from uh holland kaipa in utrecht and uh
our funding sources and bio nano for
their support
i'd like to finish by telling you that
the currently shown products are
research use only
and then i'll leave you with citing the
genius sydney brenner at the end
that tells us how important mobile
technologies are
thank you very much for your attention
thank you very much dr ocean um
we would like to um
take some time for a few uh q a
questions
um so yeah thank you again for for your
time and for your uh for your
presentation we will
ask as many questions as we have uh time
for
uh we will uh probably not have the time
to tackle every questions we will get
back to you
uh via email after this conference for
those
that we cannot answer right away um
some interesting questions uh are
regarding the filtering steps
and the amount of svs that are detected
in this uh in this technology
um can you give us uh a bit more insight
on the
uh the the filtering step that you used
uh uh
dr uh okatabi and ocean
either for the constitutional side and
uh and uh
more somatic uh detection um
for the and what are the tools that you
can use to
further filter uh the dsvs that you
identify
if you want to start with uh with uh dr
alcatavi
yeah okay um yeah thank you so
yeah i thought there was a question
about this and my slide on this
theme was not really easy to
look at actually i've shown a histogram
with the
means averages of a number of calls
and someone asked how many uh you pick
up at the beginning and it's a
few thousands like the mean is around
five to six thousand events
uh that are detected but once you
filter out with the uh population
frequency
and you pick up only rare events then
this drops
harshly down to a mean of 70 events so
we've decided to start with the
settings that are recommended by
you guys by nano actually
and which are based on a
few confidence scores on the results etc
and actually we were really happy with
the results
so we stick to it and
as i mentioned to some uh
someone from the attendees who asked me
um
we had to just play a little bit with
few filters for two cases only in our
study
um but actually the
[Music]
the recommended ones were quite good
and for dr ocean
yeah so uh so i mean leila nicely
answered it for the constitutional
changes
i think there we use very simple uh
filters obviously just for rarity of the
events
very similar to what people are used to
from the microarray field
and we did the very same also for our
research constitutional samples as i've
briefly shown you
so usually we're not by just using
trivial filters pre-selected in in bio
nano
and we just have 30 to 50 variants per
genome that are
extremely rare or unique so that already
is an absolute manageable number
for some particular cases we can also do
a dual analysis
so doing either two effectives per
family and do an overlap
or one healthy one one affected per
family and subtract the ones that are
presently healthy
and what we do more and more is
obviously running trios so unaffected
parents
to extract the de novo events i think we
all know that the novo germline
structure variants are extremely rare
uh it is still anticipated even based on
genome data that there's less than one
per genome
but if you find one that may be a more
immediate hint towards a novel disease
locus
so i think that is a very interesting
approach and it seems
that banana doesn't make too many false
positives or create a lot of noise
so the filtering for the novel seems to
work nice and straightforward
with the ability to uh to also import
bit files to
um to also uh focus the analysis so you
would keep the
the whole genome information but also
mimic a
let's say like a fish panel to uh to
highlight regions of the genome that can
be of further interest for your for your
study
correct yeah i can answer that yeah
absolutely uh
sorry i think uh let's talk briefly that
how many
of your 50 rare events overlap then with
gene
that's geno wide is only just
roughly half or 60 but if you're
interested only in the 100 genes
that are expressed at a certain moment
in a certain region of the body
then you can add that gene list and just
do an overlap without it sorry
in silico filtering for events that
overlapped with genes it's very simple
you just need a bad file
yeah great thank you a question for dr
dr katabe we can get from the
comparative study that you just
presented that um
not detecting robertsonian translocation
is is an impediment but still you state
that the
benefit risk balance is in favor of
adopting the genome
badging um and um in into your
your genetic portfolio uh can you
develop on the on the percentage of
patient presenting such uh
such uh disorder uh translocation in
your cohort
and how you intend to to deal with uh
with such
um translocation
yeah sure so um for at least for
reproductive disorders robert's phony
and translocations
are kind of
up to half of cases can have overseen
internal locations
but this is in extreme cases of
recurrent miscarriage etc uh
the the other part of the dark
reproductive disorders male infertility
female infertility the part of robert's
translocations is much lower but still
there are cases so definitely
you would not rely only on genome
imaging for those patients but
actually you can it's so easy and you
can
pick up new events probably that's our
next step
uh in such basics that it's
really interesting to move forward with
the technology
but still maintain uh at least in our
case we
we thought about it and we were we were
thinking of maintaining
a minimal count
of the few cells in addition to
genome imaging which is quite easy to
manage and imagine in a in a genetic
diagnosis lab
of course yeah as a very informative
complementary
uh technique to the to the character so
i would say
uh genome imaging as a first
uh line test and the complementary would
come from
stereotype well not a full carrier but
at least a cell count yeah to relieve
the burden on the on the on the card
a question for uh for uh dr ocean so
that the conclusion of both uh
constitutional and cancer studies
presented a hundred percent accordance
with the standard of care
uh on the retrospective cohort and and
besides you identified numerous novel
fusions and and striking leads in
unsolved cases and
what will be the next step for this
comparative study in your institute
yeah so obviously i'm working fully at
the research side
um but now we're discussing quite
actively with my colleagues at
diagnostics
what the next step is and in our view
this is
a more prospective study where we would
run the standard of care workflow
in parallel to bionano and then compare
the outcome of that
so while we still then generate our
standard results
i think as a relatively modest series of
50 to 100 samples run in parallel
would already tell us whether this is
ready for more prime time
diagnostics so i think that is something
we we will probably
do now relatively uh quickly
so perspective after this study
so um think that the the the results
on on the unanswered cases the the added
value
on the on the uh the uh the
the diagnostic side for the complement
the complement of information on on
classical physiogenetics
um we um obviously
implementing a new technology such as
such as uh
by nano in routine is a long multi-step
process
and can you both of you share your view
on what would be a realistically way to
implement
uh this technology in your institute and
first
as i understand from uh from uh dr tabby
rather in the complement
of the classical genetics and and
can you also discuss the integration
with with ngs that
is involving the same ecosystem and that
brings a different kind of information i
don't know if you want to start dr
ocean yes very happy to do so
um so i think
many genetic labs around europe or
across the world are used to lab
developed tests
um so i think for that purpose it may be
uh happening that that we start using
this as we did the first generation
market race
relatively soon even in a clinical or
pre-clinical setting
um so i think we wouldn't desperately
need to wait for
an fda approved tests for the time being
but we could just use it especially if
we convince our ourselves
as especially on these diseases
that it works and that it is better than
the standard of care
and so far we've shown that it is at
least as good
and we certainly see some advantages so
i think that may be straightforward but
maybe that is my research mind that that
sees things here
uh relatively straightforward um and
maybe
uh leila from a real diagnostic lab has
another answer to that just to very
briefly touch on your question
of the combination with mgs i i
truly see an opportunity that um we
we can generate almost perfect genomes
by combining exactly what you said bio
nano optical maps
with ngs either short or long read data
so i think we're for the first time
where we may get close to an almost
perfect genome analysis if you combine
these two essays
yeah so um there are um
two main uh situations as i mentioned
reproductive disorders
and developmental disorders and the
the decision process for each
is different right so for now at least
in europe but i think it's
overall the same everywhere in the world
reproductive disorders we still
rely on karyotypes for uh developmental
diseases
we do have pma as first line ngs
second line or first line depending on
every country
we do know the limits of karyotype for
the
first diseases and the ngs and cma
for the second so absolutely i
share with alex the statement that
for developmental disorders it would
nicely complement ngs and
we would just skip
cma analysis definitely i think
we'd have in bionano and ngs
for reproductive disorders the question
is of
the as we say the added value and the
newly diagnosed cases because we know
that keratin is
very low has very low resolution so
but still with the limit for centromeric
breakpoints i would say that again
genome imaging first and complemented by
a mini karyotype or
cell counter wire how whatever you wanna
call it uh but definitely genome imaging
has
a place to take in both tv
thank you thank you very much um we do
have a uh
some questions interesting questions
about the the kavit 19 and
is it possible that people are affected
by uh uh
by covenanting who may have chromosomal
liberation and this is a
this is an interesting question because
we we actually do have some
studies running um in in china
in in hanover in germany
uh specifically looking at the at the
incidence of
of the presence of structure variants
that may or may not
uh predispose patient to the to the
coping 19 so uh
we we had some some information released
on our website and feel free to uh
to get back to us to get more
information about this we would be happy
to to to put you in touch with the
with the people leading these uh these
studies
um some i'm just scrolling through the
sort of question over there um
we
i'm sorry there's just so many questions
pouring in that
it's difficult to to uh um
scroll through them uh maybe a question
for uh dr
ocean uh what is the anticipated rate of
fail
test failure with uh with leukemia
sample and especially
uh one with uh with bone marrow front
bombardier
so just the blunt and honest answer is
i think in the first month we we tried
some bondwear samples that were not
recommended
and we used much lower input than by
nano recommended us to use
and those samples can fail absolutely
since then we're a bit more strict
to just follow exactly the q and c uh
um yeah so the quality checks that by by
nano gives
and since then we have almost no
failures i idea to say
so if you use 1.5 million cells if you
use the dna stabilizer in your sample
directly
and that is either bone marrow aspirates
or heparinized or edta blots
then i think the failure rate is
extremely low at the moment
um obviously that may be different if
your sample is shipped around the entire
globe
so if the cells are not intact and your
molecules are not intact
then you won't manage so i think as for
some of the sequencing essays here it's
even more important
to learn the lessons that um yeah
basically garbage in would be garbage
out but if you have high quality cells
then i think the the chance of
successful experiences is very high by
now
very good we are uh way past time for
this uh for this session
um we do have some questions about
pricing um how much does it cost to to
to run
uh a sample on the on optical mapping
so the best person to answer would be
of course to get in touch with uh with
our uh uh original
business managers and that can provide
you with all the different information
uh about the three different ways to get
by nano
either by the through the service
by sending us directly to sample through
a regent rental
uh or through buying directly the system
but the
the pricing uh starts at 450
per sample but just get back uh in touch
with us
uh and we will be happy to to put you in
touch
with uh your local uh regional business
manager
um thank you again dr alcatabi and ocean
for your uh research for your
presentation
and before we go i would like to to
thank the audience for
joining us today and for all the
interesting questions we didn't have
time to uh
tackle all the questions uh they really
poured in
at the last minute but we will address
uh
them um and and we will provide you with
uh with answers in that in the following
days thank you again to uh to uh both
our
speakers this webcast will be uh can be
viewed
on demand after this this uh this
session
and labrus will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and until next time thank you again
and goodbye